and now welcome to another episode of
tiger belly my name my name is Eleanor
Gigi Rick Mangla energy Rick Monday yes
hello hello how was your day at the
factory what factory [ __ ] I
thought you were sewing today yes I was
sewing the factory and we were making
this quilt made out of foot foot is it
that foot okay can I just say something
yeah I haven't slept in my face
I almost look like today's so this is
gonna go real crazy because because you
know what I want to do a good job too
because we have such a good gasp oh damn
I'm frightened I'm frightened of what I
might do it what I might say do the top
countdown again I gotta start over 5 4 3
2 1 hello my name is Robert Norrell
[Laughter]
we've got um judge in the house we've
got good light
[ __ ] you my kalila we got kalila we got
gilbert we got rice rice who wants to
[ __ ] my girlfriend no guys [ __ ] eyes all
the time I'm tell you right now Bryce
out of all the dudes you're probably
gonna be the one I would be okay with
the one - what your delegate no just to
pursue it you're not gonna give it to
him I know oh I thought you been the one
that I what you sell her to you pawning
me off just you know if if she it was if
human slavery was in and it wasn't
illegal
I would sell her to you for a lot of
money for like a hundred bucks because
he's like that's a lot that's a lot of
money horrible bill you know you're
worth it babe you're with it yeah but
our guest tonight from just kidding
films Joe Jitsu cow
yo have any Bobby Jojo finally well you
know we got the two more important
people from just kidding films out of
the way we got Barca one all the way
Giovanni they're the leaders and they're
the main ones they're my we decided to
you know just kind of clean up and get
to like the back people the main guys to
our live shows ya know Joe you've been
yeah I'm telling right now
you were the you're the number one yeah
I don't know why the [ __ ] but the thing
is is that um you've always been the
number one but I don't know like whoever
[ __ ] booked it
you're like Gio's come who's geo shows
up I'm like what the [ __ ] apart Kwan's
coming I don't know that you texted Bart
oh yeah that's right yep but Joe just
Okawa when I was in France and then and
in Bart you have Bart on the show yeah
my heart ripped apart he's my boy I was
sad dude why because I actually listen
to Tiger belly I know those things I
know right now I know but they are de
fakers and I can tell by them like
they're not real people when they are
real you can't say oh now look what you
did yeah you can't do it called me to
test you oh really yeah [ __ ] they call
me test you and you passed the test in
front can I also a lot you know why I
like you your you know every Asian
there's like two types yeah there's
regular and this is my favorite type
cross-eyed my favorite cross I like you
you know else has it jamie chung a
little bit you know david childress he
has a little bit of cross-eyed you have
a little cross-eyed yeah I love
cross-eyed because it means you're a
little [ __ ] it means that you you or
there's a little bit of something
missing not a little
a lot of yeah yeah special and out of
all the just kidding people I think that
you are the most similar to me you have
said that you are my future that's not
good for you does that feel good this is
what you want this piece of [ __ ] yeah
you have awesome friends you have no
friends
if to eat dogs they don't like me they
buy him oh yeah
I generally are generally you know I
think the only one that in this world
that really I think vaguely loves me
deeply is kalila my parents I think my
parents love me kind of Steve loves
relies you know kalila loves intensely
intense and well okay vaguely
I think Gilbert um he's off and on you
know yeah I think George I don't know
where I think he's secretly hate hates
me I think he secretly hates me Bryce I
don't give a [ __ ] what Bryce but my
point is is that you don't want to be me
man you want to be you you know what
you'd have a brighter future than me I
really do okay because 100 percent it's
at the end of the road for me my friend
[Music]